À travers les époques et les dangers ,
Une grande aventure les appelle :
C'est , c'est , c'est
L'Épopée Temporelle
Chers auditeurs ,
nous retrouvons Iris, Elliott, Thomas et Thomas du futur en 1503 à Florence .Ils sont à la recherche d'un malfaiteur
qui modifie le cours du temps... mais qui est t'il ? J'ai lu vos théories dans les commentaires c'est très intéressant.
Notamment celui de saitama zz qui dit c'est ta mère qui modifie le temps !!!
Cent trente sept pouces en l'air ! C'est beau internet !!
Ahh la renaissance , l'âge d'or de la peinture à l'huile ! C'est romantique,
Ohh regardez j'ai une nouvelle robe ! - Magnifique !! - Ben , j'suis habillé comme sur le Titanic moi ?!
- On compte sur vous pour arrêter cette personne qui modifie le temps ... et pour me mettre cinq étoiles si vous êtes satisfait du voyage !!!
Ahh , Ahh , oh non , AHHHHHHHHH , je disparais encore ! Oh putain d'merde !
- Il a encore disparu ! - À tout à leur petit lapin ! - D'après mes capteurs, l'anomalie viendrait de ce bâtiment.
-Atelier de Léona..vous avez lu ? c'est l'atelier de Léonard de Vinci !
-La porte est fermée . - Ne bougez pas !  J'en fais mon affaire !
Ne vous débattez pas, çà sera moins douloureux !
-Regardez Léonard de Vinci est ligoté. - Vous essayez de contrecarrer mes plans ?
- Ohh , un robot !! - N'essayez pas de me barrer la route je fais ça pour le bien de l'humanité ! - J'ai un plan on n'a qu'à renverser du coca dessus !!
Comme j'ai fait avec mon ordi .
- Pas le temps pour ça : je vais t'arrêter robot ! - Ahh quel courage ! - Merci ! -Je parle de lui-  Et lui c'est moi bientôt! J'accepte tes compliments .
-Ohh là là !
- Allez futur moi je veux le faire !! -Fais bobos au robot !
- Continue !
Regardez le bouger , non mais
Ouhh , j'ai chaud moi !!!
- HaHa , tu es fort !
HaHa mais pas assez pour m'arrêter !! - Qui es tu ?
- Pourquoi détruire le temps ?
- Détruire...
Haha !
Nous améliorons le temps et vous ne m'attraperez pas !
- Elle s'est échappée.
- C'est un échec, je n'ai pas pu la neutraliser.
- Ne t'inquiète pas tu t'es bien défendu, ça arrive d'échouer.
- Tout le temps même !
- Robot, j'ai récupéré une pièce détachée, analyse là tout de suite.
- S'il te plaît Elliott car je suis un être "vivant et sensible".
Pas de doute Iris,  ce robot vient bien de notre époque.
Mais qui est-ce ?
- Attendez monsieur...
Voilà ! Vous êtes libre monsieur Dicaprio.
- De Vinci.
- Merci à vous étrangers, cette étrange femme voulait me voler mes plans, mais vous êtes arrivés à temps.
- C'est un honneur de vous rencontrer.
- Merci !
- Je suis très sensible à vos oeuvres, elles me procurent des "émotions"
- Oui ! On est très émus de rencontrer un tel génie !
- Je suis plutôt fier de mes dessins d'armes, elles vont être dévastatrices !
- Ah oui vos peintures sont magnifiques !
La Cène, La Joconde...
La Joconde ? Comment vous êtes au courant ?
Je n'ai même pas encore terminé de la peindre
C'est parce qu'on vient du futur !
*Murmurement* Ta gue*le Thomas ! Tu veux modifier le temps ?
- Quoi ?
- Ah oui m*rde ! J'avais oublié !
- Des voyageur du temps, dans mon atelier !
OH ! Formidable !
J'en ai toujours rêvé !
- En chair et en os !
- Ainsi que d'autres matériaux.
- Dites-moi, mes travaux sont connus dans l'avenir ?
- Mais grave ! Y'a eu le film là euh... Da Vinci Code !
- Mais non ! Mes armes rotatives par exemple ?
- Plutôt les tableaux.
- Et mes appareils volants ?
- Ça c'est plutôt des prototypes, non ?
- Et ça ?
- Un dessin... Ah tiens, on dirait une fourchette d'un côté une lame de couteau de l'autre.
- Oui ! J'ai même fait un prototype !
j'ai appelé ça... le fourteau !
La couchette ça existe déjà.
mais si le manche de la fourchette est une lame , ça coupe la main quand on la prends, non ??
Aiiiie !!!
Oui ...ça coupe la main !
Ca là, le... le fourteau... bon, j'avoue qu'on s'en souvient pas trop... mais vous allez marquer l'avenir avec la Joconde ! Mais vous allez marquer l'avenir avec la Joconde !
Quoi ? Mais  c'est juste une commande... le portrait de la femme d'un marchand de tapis... je fais ça pour m'venger !
en plus elle est moche ! *rire*,  ils ont même voulu que je lui enlève les sourcils !
vous serez célebre grâce  à ce tableau !
Jamais de la vie !!
-Il prend visiblement mal les compliments...
Oui c'est le choc, mais... il va se calmer !
-Coucou , me revoilà !
Vous êtes sûr ?
Adieu, tableau de merde !
Parce qu'il vient de jeter le tableau dans la cheminée !
Non !! Pas la Joconde !!
hors de question que je sois connu pour çà !
-Oh non, je re-disparaît !!
et bah  bravo Iris , il vient de modifier le temps !
Tais-toi
Thomas a raison il faut remplacer ce tableau pour rétablir le cours du temps !
M...Monsieur De Vinci ! Vous voulez pas repeindre un autre tableau ?
Genre exactement le même que la Joconde ?
non !  je vais faire un autre projet qui sera réellement mon chef-d'oeuvre !
Peut-être que si il refait un chef-d'oeuvre, çà ne changeras pas le cours du temps ?
J'ai besoin d'un modèle !
Quelqu'un... qui m'éblouit !
Qui m'inspire !
Allez vite ! Maintenant !! Ahah !
je dois peindre mon oeuvre !
Boooon bah...J'suis pas fan de "poser" pour un vieux monsieur, mais si c'est pour sauver le temps, bah...
les cheveux détachés ça vous va ?
Ah non !  Pas toi !
tu es une belle fille !
Comme on en trouve plein partout ! En revanche, toi oui !
Toi ! C'est toi que je vais peindre !
Moi ?
Lui ??
Thomas du passé ?
Mon ancien "moi" ?
Oui !! Le garçon moche au milieu !
Aah ce visage ! Cette expression de subir le monde ! cette lâcheté débordante ! cette carrure frêle !
-C'est bien çà ?-     C'est révolutionnaire!  c'est différent !
Je veux de la joie dans le corps de la tristesse !
le corps de la tristesse ?
Oui ! Il me faut du mouvement ! C'est terminé les poses statiques !  Les mains croisées...
Que fais tu quand tu es heureux?? Hmm ?  tu souris, tu danses !
Montre moi !  je veux peindre çà !
Bah une fois j'ai fait Top 1 à Fortnite, j'étais trop content , alors j'ai dabbé ...comme çà !
Ah ! Magnifique ! les bras en l'air !
Vite !! mes pinceaux !!
Enlève tes vêtements ! Enlève tout ! Je dois te peindre au naturel !
C'est obligé ?? Non... Par...Parce qu'il fait un peu froid... Enfin je dis çà comme ça...
Oh mon Dieu ! Mais qu'est ce qu'on a fait ?
J'espère que ça va marcher sinon on est bloqués ici pour toujours !
Sortez tous !! Laissez nous ! Je dois me concentrer sur mon chef-d'oeuvre...
ok ok on va attendre dans le restaurant en face ...
Oh non ! Reste avec eux...Et préviens nous en cas de danger...
S'il te plaît Eliott...
avec plaisir thomas ! je reste avec thomas du passé !
monsieur De Vinci , un café ?
C'est quoi ?
Vous allez adorer !
Et voilà votre commande !
Merci mademoiselle !
Cà me fait plaisir qu'on prennent un p'tit goûter, seuls... toi et moi...
c'est un plaisir pour moi aussi la posture assise dans mon monde c'est pas tous les jours
cet endroit est tellement romantique !
Dans mon monde, je n'ai connu que la violence et le sang de mes ennemis...
je dois dire que cette Pana Cotta est délicieuse !
Je suis un peu embêtée... J'aimerais te parler de quelque chose qui me...
bouleverse...
Je sais ce que tu vas me dire...Et je ressens la même chose...
Non... C'est vrai ?
j'ai l'impression que c'est mal mais c'est plus fort que moi...
Il n'y a pas de honte à avoir... C'est un sentiment naturel...
Il est si... Spécial...
Quoi ?
sensible ...
Qui ?
Il montre ses failles...
Non...
Il s'inquiète pour les autres...
attends tu veux parler de...
J'aimerais être à nouveau ce Thomas là !
Comment ai-je pu me perdre autant chemin ? J'avais oublié à quel point j'étais pur avant...
ce que j'ai vécu...
Ah je suis... je suis choquée, là...
Je comprends que tu puisse être
irrésistiblement attiré par cette version de moi !
Non c'était plus de toi en fait, que je...
Je regarde mes mains, et je vois la violence que j'ai dû endurer... Je regarde mes bras, et je vois les problèmes que j'ai dû affronter...
je regarde mes abdos et je vois des boues de pierres taillées en profondeur parcourues  par des veines saillantes sur ma peau fine et luisante
j'ai perdu mon innocence et ce jeune thomas c'est tout ce que je recherche il n'attend qu'une chose
donner de l'amour...
Je voyais pas du tout çà comme ça...
les amis ! le tableau est fini !  vous n'allez pas être déçus ou peut-être que oui
Voici mon chef-d'oeuvre !
Cette joie das la posture...-Je valide !-  Ces mouvements de bras inédits...
je l'ai appelée... "Le Dabbeur"
J'suis un chef-d'oeuvre !
Dommage qu'on voit pas mon visage...
Le modèle était si inspirant...
non j'ai caché les parties intimes avec une toute petite
pâquerette ah bah c'est mieux comme ça... -Alors pour ma défense il faisait froid-
Ah ouais, on est loin d'être au niveau de la Joconde là...
c'est foutu
Le dabbeur !
T'es là ?
C'est fou de le voir en vrai !
Il est tout neuf ! Encore plus coloré qu'au Louvres !
quel chef-d'oeuvre !
On a réussi à maintenir le temps ?
Bah oui, apparament...
J'allais vous re-déposer à votre époque mais, on va devoir faire un nouveau détour...
Il y a un nouveau problème...
Un nouveau voyage à travers les époques et les dangers?
Une grande aventure vous appelle...
C'est, c'est, c'est... Où qu'on va ?
pénalisation !
Au revoir, voyageurs du futur !
Nous sommes arrivés ! N'oubliez pas de...
OH NON ! Je disparaît !
J'adore ces vêtements ! Regarder  mes bottes ! Et mon chapeau !
Nouvelle époque ! Nouvelle robes ! J'adore !
Nous sommes en Amérique !
En l'an..
Je comprends jamais avec tes dates , Eliott !
Tu peux être moins précis ?
Ok...Simplification en cours ...
Amérique du Nord, 18ème sièc...
Plus simple !!
Ok... /INFOS POUR ENFANTS/:
Amérique...Epoque des Cows-Boys !
Oh mais c'est pour çà que vous êtes en cows-boys !
Heennn... Mais pourquoi je suis encore habillé pareil ?
D'après mes capteurs, l'anomalie est quelque part dans la région...
WOW !
C'était quoi çà ?
"Un canon à antimatière..."
Ben tu vois , saitama zz  ! C'était pas ma mère qui cherche à modifier le temps , mais un robot .
Dommage, j'aimais bien ma théorie sur Adolf Hitler...
Mais quel est ce rayon étrage qui traverse le ciel à l'époque des cows-boys ?
J'ai aussi ma petite idée...
Merci d'avoir écouté ce troisième épisode de l'épopée temporelle et à la semaine prochaine pour la suite !